was there a worry or a sort of
hesitation to know that that next day
you would be sitting down beside jasmine
well fifty people asked her if she was
still in love with mikkel um that wasn't
part of it that wasn't part of us
canceling a day because uh time had
passed again people seem to think we're
in Cuba this day the next day's the
after the fun I mean time it passed
we've had a month since we filmed that
show yeah um like I'm friends with
Miguel like we understand we understand
how the show works and we've got we've
got through it together that that wasn't
the concern it was more just we were
very emotional together we spent the
whole next day just the two of us some
ubereats and just conversations and we
just needed that we just we weren't able
to go through with just sitting like
this all day yeah Mikkel who has a
girlfriend now by the way right that's
good he's happy for him yeah of course
it um when it comes to this it is
reality to you but it's reality
television to everybody who watches if
there was something that you could say
to people to just let them know how real
it is when it comes to their comments
the way that they perceive people the
way that the show was done what do you
hope people get out of your experience
on this show I mean I'm so thankful that
people have invested themselves enough
to care
and for the most part people have been
really kind and and I've been really
appreciative of that but um I think
people should understand that we are
just regular folks who came into this
and this is all very new for us and we
really do just want to be able to
approach a real relationship together
and hopefully people will get that yeah
that's a pretty new um what are the
plans there's something that wasn't
discussed on after the final rose that's
usually when they talk to you about
who's moving where what are you doing
yeah what are the plans we didn't get
any of that I know I think that they
could tell Noah could tell that the
energy was kind of off and sort of avoid
avoided pushing any further with us
today um to be honest like we're like I
said this last week has been the best
week of our relationship and it's
because we've taken the pressure off of
ourselves and off of each other and
we've just had a really normal
relationship totally disconnected
and so that's gonna be our approach
moving forward is we're not thinking
about marriage we're not even thinking
about your gauge we're engaged we're
engaged engaged for a long time we're
just I'm gonna go visit her next month
and we're gonna just go snowboarding and
just take it from there we're not we're
not you're not talking about moving in
together
it we've talked about it but we're
completely taking it step by step right
it's the best way for us we've realized
because the more pressure on us the more
we just feel a little bit overwhelmed
and it's been amazing to take the
pressure off of each other like it's
crazy the difference that that has made
right you guys still fight not as Bob no
not as that this week is actually been
great this week is been great I mean
yeah we were surprised how how we came
together like the utility that we faced
it brought us actually closer together
did and we never fought bad it's just
him I are completely different people we
have very different personalities yeah
and we've been just slowly adjusting to
each other and it's been worth it like
the effort has been worth it because I
mean he's not a stubborn guy if I have
something and I don't like the way that
he approaches something like for example
him leaving during arguments there's no
chance that it will ever do that again
right great
well who could who got it worse on
social media I'm saying I time I can
take it though I I felt worse for her
because she didn't deserve she chose me
she doesn't deserve to be ripped apart
for it I understand that if you don't
like the way I look or the way I talk
and not even like the way I talk Ross I
don't know I want to hold on a second I
didn't say I didn't like the way you tie
was trying to watch the election and I
was doing those messages saying how much
I talk over the side of my mouth have
you
which is great um
no III could take it I was so used to up
by this point
I mean team Mike team Mikkel
Kevin's this Kevin's that that's fine I
was used to it I think it was the
Tuesday night hearing the negative stuff
about her for choosing me I just wanted
to take that away I felt really really
bad for her for that she didn't deserve
that she's just an honest person that
put herself fully into this thing and
she should get credit for that not right
now for I've said you are the best
Bachelorette or bachelor that has ever
been I agree they show you are the most
open when it comes to your emotions you
call BS when you see BS and you've set
the bar as far as how open and honest
somebody has to be on this show and I
think that it was that honesty with you
which led fans to be so protective of
you and which built the emotional bond
with people who watched it which forced
us to live that fantasy with you and
that's where all that that's where all
that comes from now that it's no longer
the fantasy and it's a reality it's a
different thing right yeah yeah and I
and I know that a lot of the the
negativity towards my choice has been
because people are just trying to be
protective of me like I find that really
sweet at the same time but um but I know
that there's only a fraction of the
story that they're really seeing